today the focus of our daily
cancellation is a guy named kyle
kalinski who's a youtuber he has
more subscribers than me on youtube but
then i have more followers than him on
twitter so the question of
which of us is a better person remains
there for undecided i guess we'll have
to compare facebook friends
anyway kyle dedicated a segment of his
show recently to addressing
me and an argument that i've made about
masking the title of the video with this
segment is
conservative weirdo really really mad at
mask wearers
i don't deny that um i'm probably a
weirdo
but not because of my masking stance
that is without question the least weird
thing about me
kyle is specifically upset with me over
a recent tweet of mine on this issue i
believe i've already addressed this
tweet on the show but here it is for
your reference again i wrote wearing a
mask when not when it is not medically
necessary is grotesque and on human an
attack on society itself it feeds
paranoia and fear
you're treating air like it's toxic and
other humans like they're nothing but
vessels of disease it is disgraceful
arrogant and offensive
before we get to kyle's rebuttal let's
just once again consider the point that
i'm making
i stipulate that i am referring to
medically unnecessary masks
masks i realize there are for example
people with serious illnesses or
compromised immune systems
who might wear a mask and would have
worn one before all of this
there are other scenarios too like let's
say you have severe allergies and you're
out cutting the grass i've always seen
some people wearing masks because of
that no problem i'm not talking about
any of those categories or similar
categories
what we're talking about is the
medically unnecessary masking so
as for that let's take it line by line
here
i call unnecessary masking grotesque and
unhuman
that's correct the only problem here
perhaps is the redundancy
it's grotesque because it is on human
humans acting in unhuman ways
are always grotesque and i would say
it's unhuman it's indeed an attack on in
the rejection of human society
when you walk around as if each person
who even passes by you on the sidewalk
might infect you with a disease and kill
you
to treat your fellow humans as
disease-carrying rodents
who are very likely to make you sick
even just by being in your general
vicinity for a few moments
is to my mind severely dysfunctional
behavior it is not mere caution
okay a man who washes his hands
periodically throughout the day
and after using the bathroom before
making food etc is cautious and
practicing good hygiene we should all be
cautious like that
but a man who scrubs at his hands for 45
minutes at a time
until they're bleeding is not cautious
he's sick
he's deeply disturbed and the masking
that i'm referring to
is worse in some ways than that because
the masker is projecting his pathologies
outward broadcasting them
wearing them on his face literally
i also say that it feeds paranoia and
fear i think that's pretty self-evident
it's the height of paranoia for a
physically healthy person who's not at
any significant risk of covet either
because of vaccination or prior
infection or whatever other reason
to to walk around as though they might
get infected if they if they allow
themselves to breathe
fresh air for a few moments paranoid
yeah absolutely that's paranoid
and yes it feeds paranoia in others
again it projects it outwards encourages
it spreads it
spreads it much like the disease that
it's ostensibly supposed to be
to be protecting from as for disgraceful
arrogant and offensive well
yes i would call it arrogant to treat
your fellow humans like they're nothing
but a threat to you
like they're sick diseased toxic plague
carrying
rats i would call that arrogant
absolutely
offensive i mean what does what does
offensive mean an act is offensive if
it's insulting
rude disrespectful and derogatory
i i do believe that the word offensive
is way overused i often complain about
its overuse
but i never said i never said that
nothing is offensive obviously some
things actually are offensive
the word means something and that
meaning applies
sometimes just because i object to its
overuse doesn't mean that i object to
its use
period and in this case yes i would say
it is offensive
to treat other people that way and to
treat society that way
okay so i have now reiterated my points
and explain them
i've argued my case i wanted to do that
ahead of time before we got to
kyle's rebuttal of the conservative
weirdo i.e yours truly
so i want to just as for for you know
to set the stage that's all of that
explaining it
now let's listen to uh kyle now the
conservatives now that uh the
government agencies decided if you're
vaccinated you don't really need to wear
it inside
um conservatives are aggressively coming
out
to i guess do their version of an end
zone dance
so there's this guy matt walsh who's a
conservative commentator and here's what
he says
wearing a mask when it is not medically
necessary
is grotesque and unhuman an attack on
society
itself it feeds paranoia and fear
you are treating air like it is toxic
and other humans like they are nothing
but vessels of disease
it is disgraceful arrogant and offensive
so now you have the anti-mask
brigade is becoming militant in their
anti-maskiness
that's what we're currently watching
look at the language he's using
so the government admits like okay
vaccinated people don't need to wear it
inside
and this is what this guy's reaction is
it is
wearing a mask is not medic wearing a
mask when it's not medically necessary
is grotesque
unhuman an attack on society itself it
feeds paranoia and fear
and you're treating air like it's toxic
and other humans like they are nothing
but vessels of disease
it is disgraceful arrogant and offensive
offensive these are the guys who call
other people snowflakes 24 7.
these are the guys who go after the libs
for being triggered
these are the guys who make fun of safe
spaces it sounds like this guy needs a
safe space for masks
so listen it's easy to dunk on this guy
and and have fun with it
it's easy to dunk then why haven't you
get around to it kyle you can start
dunking any time if it's so easy at
least pull off a couple of windmills
just to show us what you got
i mean you're saying it's so easy to
dunk on this absurd position from a
weirdo and yet all you've done so far is
repeat my argument
in an incredulous voice that doesn't
count as an argument
raising your eyebrows and restating what
i said in a mocking tone is not a
rebuttal
a parrot could could literally do that a
bird could do that
just without the eyebrows i suppose
let's see if kyle gets around to
actually making an argument of some kind
at some point
so let's continue you shouldn't be
offend if somebody's outside
and they're not wearing a mask that's
fine they don't need to wear a mask
everybody relax
if somebody's outside and they are
wearing a mask they're being overly
cautious but
that's totally fine that's totally fine
if somebody's indoors and they're not
wearing a mask and they're vaccinated
that's fine if somebody's indoors
and they're wearing a mask and they're
unvaccinated or
vaccinated i think that's fine
i think it's fine i don't know why
this became the ultimate like culture
war issue but i just want to be clear
that everybody participating in it looks
colossally stupid
and honestly looking back at a tweet
like this in retrospect from the future
and this guy being considered an
intellectual on the right kind of
embarrassing for the right
i mean this guy saying stuff like this
it's like they're
proudly wearing their
anti-intellectualism
you know and
it's just sad i just sort of feel bad
for this guy
who's 100 percent caught in the culture
war and stuck
and he's like brainwashed by it to the
point where he says deranged
stuff like this well thank you for your
pity kyle
i don't need it though not for this
anyway a month from now i'll be going on
a vacation with four kids driving 16
hours
and i'll need your pity for that so
please store it up for that sort of
emergency
as for the tweet you're responding to i
feel great about it in fact we are in
the future right now and i'm looking
back on that and i couldn't be happier
that i said it
especially because nothing you have said
in response to it qualifies in any way
as an
argument you seem very sure that my
argument is incomprehensibly stupid and
yet you're unable to actually explain
why
your entire rebuttal is yeah but i think
it's fine
i think it's fine it's fine
i'm glad you do but you say that i'm
anti-intellectual
and i never claimed to be an
intellectual in the first place i care
less
what label you put there um but to show
off your own intellectual prowess you
have eviscerated my position with
eloquent rhetorical flourishes like
he's a weirdo this is stupid and my
favorite
i mean this guy saying stuff like this
that was probably that was my favorite
counterpoint
that you raised i mean this guy come on
saying this stuff forget about it
very profound points kyle i don't mean
to pick on you but
this is a serious problem these days and
you just provide us with a handy example
of the problem people seem to think
that scoffing counts as an argument they
think that if they
encounter an idea that they consider
extreme all they have to do is smirk and
laugh and say
that's extreme and that'll be sufficient
to debunk
the idea it's not and it's especially
not in my case because i'm not
embarrassed to be labeled extreme
i don't care extreme just means i've
taken a position that's outside of
mainstream thought
and considering that mainstream thought
is so often shallow superficial
half-baked and misguided
i'm quite pleased whenever i find myself
outside of it
and the mainstream thought on masking
right now is that although masks have
existed for hundreds of years
and almost everyone went about their
lives without them and showed their
faces
and breathed the air and interacted with
other neighbors with other people and
their neighbors like
normal humans now all of a sudden there
ought to be a tectonic shift where it's
considered normal or even advisable to
cover your mouth and nose
whenever you leave the house as if the
very air itself is radioactive
my point is that my extreme view
is actually just the mainstream view
of 15 months ago and every point before
that
the only difference is that i am not
floating with the tide of mainstream
opinion
i'm not going to radically recalibrate
my view of the world and of society
every time our culture
tells me that i should if that's your
approach
so be it but it's not
and so for that reason today
unfortunately i have to say
that our friend kyle is canceled
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated